what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interviews YouTube channel for
a special one I was really looking
forward to seeing this performance and
he did not disappoint Coleman Domingo
for Rustin so I was recently talking to
Ay Kaufman and she was telling me you
can't miss this performance this is one
you're going to be talking about for
months to come and then beyond and she
she was not wrong you are something else
in this movie oh Perry thank you so much
I appreciate that I I this film was made
with so much love and respect and honor
for this unsung hero of many and I I
know that it was I I I'm glad that it's
being received with his much love truly
because it's really um it's Monumental
yeah it's pulling this man out of the
Shadows of history and giving him his
moment you truly feel it while you're
watching it I feel like that love does
radiate off the screen all right I'm
starting with a really big question
inspired by the film cuz I really love
the idea that's mentioned at the very
beginning owning your power so I wanted
to apply that to your career overall and
this business can you pinpoint a moment
where you first learned the power of
your own voice on set and to start your
start to own your power in this industry
wow that's a great question per that's
great wow you you came you hit hard
that's good you know what I think the
very first thing I think when it came to
own my power was actually as a young
actor I used to be very frustrated with
the roles that I was you know being
offered to audition as a young black man
in the world I was getting all these
roles that were you know drug dealer
number two you name it and I remember my
mother told me she I was so frustrated
one time she says you know well don't
complain about it you have to do
something about it so that's why I
became a writer so I decided to write
the roles that I wanted to see and
actually by writing and then Direct Ing
and producing I started to feel like I
had power I I had power with what
stories I wanted to tell and then I
wanted to empower my fellow brothers and
sisters white black and other like write
these stories write these incredible
stories about women you write it let's
not just wait for the industry to write
it do it yourself so that's when I
actually started to own my power and
that was maybe when I was 21 years old
and then and then I think that that
power has led me into the rooms that
I've been in and it's um people know
that when you hire me you're hiring
somebody who definitely has a voice I
will definitely like they you know
you're going to get every part of me I'm
going to help lead a set or talk about
how we build this thing uh I'm not just
going to show up and learn my lines and
hit my marks I'm going to figure out how
is how are they being taken care of in
in the theater they they call me um
there's always a role for the equity
Deputy that's the role that you know you
have you know if you you don't know that
my friends out there it's the role that
the company says oh this is the person
you go to if there's any problems with
with anything you talk to the producers
you talk that and it's always me it's
always been me so I've always been a
person I guess who felt like I had a
sense of power in this industry and it
started when I was about 21 you know
Equity Deputy I love that should be in
the special skills section I'm
like that I do want to get into you
being a leader on this set and I'm gonna
do it this way because I heard in
another interview someone say that this
was actually your first lead role in a
feature film and like my jaw dropped I
couldn't believe it I know right it's
it's wild because you know I've been
people say that oh they people always
know me when I see people in the street
they they know I'm that guy but they
don't know what movie they've seen me in
because I sort of shape shift and and
I'm always a supporting player and you
never know where I'm going to pop out
and I change my weight and my age and my
accents and you name it and so so that
that was happening for a very long time
and then the idea for this role I feel
like the role to sort of match sort of
my heart desire uh the idea that I can
give everything I could as an actor for
a role like this was everything so I
knew I know I had everything to give to
it but also I know was experience of
like 32 years in the making you know I
didn't just get out of grad school and
get my first lead role I mean many
people have and that's wonderful but my
experience was I get to bring in this
whole life
experience and make sure that this truly
counts in every single way it sounds
like you have always has known how to be
a really good leader on a production but
can you pinpoint maybe a pass number one
on the call sheet who inspired you in
terms of How They Carried themselves on
set and influenced the people around
them well first wow how beautiful is
that immediately made me think of Sam
Waton on Law and Order actually I
remember and I don't know if he's number
one on the call sheet but I was a young
actor and as a young actor as a day
player you go on these sets and you try
to figure out how to navigate this it's
so many moving pieces and you even think
you how do you even learn your lines or
there's so much
happening you know and Sam had such a
Grace and warmth and he was very
pleasant and he had a great work EIC
that I would start to watch I watched
the way he sort of built up his scenes
he started slowly and built him he was
patient with himself and he's also very
kind and I I know that he there was a
seat planted there I thought like in
this storm of
production kindness is the most
important thing so true it's so true I I
wish that was emphasized even more than
it actually is because I feel like it
would completely change the nature of
this business I completely agree 100% it
and I think I know that's a thing that I
wanted to make sure because I have a lot
of young actors in This film and a lot
of them was their first film so in part
I was becoming their Sam Waton you know
I want to show them how to lead because
I expect them all to lead someday and I
think I figured out a beautiful way to
do it to make sure everyone's heard and
everyone feels valued and everyone has
an incredible work ethic and you can you
really can it it it takes everyone it's
such a team effort and not one person is
more worthy than the other every PA
every Transportation every grip we all
have a job to do but I think it's up to
the number one the number one has to be
the soul of the production
it's actually not up to the producers
it's like it's that person who's going
to be on that set every single day and
on Rustin I was on set 14 hours a day
every day maybe I had two days off of
the whole production but it requires you
to to to lead and show how to get it
done and I think it can be done with
such Grace and peace and love yeah
absolutely I will now pivot to another
leader on this sex I'm a big fan of
George of course you two have worked
together so big old compound question
about working with him again what is
something he did for you on the set of
mareni that you were you're very excited
to experience again on this film but
then also is there anything he did for
you on the set of Rustin that made you
look at him and go like I knew you were
good but I didn't realize you were that
good well that's a great question on my
rainy George likes to have private
rehearsals with his actors and which is
great and that really means truly
private that's no DP no first ad just
himself and the actors and there was
this one time where he pulled me aside
when I was going to do my I have a
monologue towards the end of my rainy uh
and he said uh colan um let's go through
the monologue we went through it he says
uh you've been directing a lot lady
haven't you I said yeah I have and I
said it with such pride and he said he
said I can tell he said you know too
much and I was like what does that mean
I think isn't that a good thing he said
it is sort of he said but as an actor
you have to liberate yourself and you
have to go to that space of not knowing
he said not saying you don't need to
know your lines and and your research
and all you know all this stuff but you
Coleman also know the shape of the scene
and what you're going for aesthetically
and I want you to actually experience it
and liberate yourself because it may
change it may be different and unique
and I thought that was the best note I
could get after doing this for so long
it felt like it was like rest starting
the way I create again and then um and
so I took that into Rustin and with
Rustin I just loved to be very honest
there's a word that I'll say that um I
found with George that I didn't know I
was going to get with Rustin which was a
sense of um delicacy being delicate he's
very delicate with me because also I
think that he knew how much I had to
shoulder but um because George is a he's
a Workhorse and he's he's he he makes
sure people up the task he's very clear
about it he's very strong mind and
strong willed and he's you know he's
tough in a good way but he had a a sense
I knew he could um he knew there needed
to be a delicacy in this um film and he
was very delicate with me and I think
that that was um something new for me to
experience kindness and delicacy I want
that on every set out there yeah all
right let's get into the specifics of
bringing Rustin to screen this is a a a
big question and something I'm always
curious about for any actor bringing a
real person to screen in a film but I'm
especially curious in your case because
I've heard you describe v as a
caricature someone who you know kind of
created himself in a sense for other
people so when you're playing a real
person like that how do you draw the
line between impersonation and bringing
a fully realized authentic and layered
version of that person to screen well
first thank that's a great question the
first thing is there's so many things
about byard which is um so fascinating
the idea that this man was openly gay at
that time not only openly gay he played
the loot he sang Elizabeth and love
songs recording an album he was on
Broadway he was an a star athlete he was
an organizer he was a war resistor he
was a young communist who is this guy
you they don't make him like that you
know and on top of it he had if you go
through his
research debates and interviews he has
this Mid-Atlantic standard is accent and
you're like what is what is wait it it
sounds British at times and there times
you're like but no that sounds like a
little like Katherine heurn and you're
like wait what is this accent and asked
um relle Horwitz who is one of his um
dear dear friends and comrades who
actually organized Transportation when
she was 19 years old for by Rustin for
the March in Washington I said what was
this accent she say oh he made that up I
was like he made it up that's fantastic
he really truly was his own creation you
know he wore his hair up in like a very
high on his head shocking gray in a time
when brother juji had sharp Fades and
stuff like that and very you know for
the movement but he was really just like
kind of a hippie in a way so I was like
oh great this is a lot to um put on so I
actually worked my voice which his voice
is like about three octaves High than
mine and I worked that accent and I
created that in our rehearsals and at
some point George was like he loved it
but he also said okay that's great I
want to make sure we're not doing
mimicry if you could bring him down a
bit more closer to your voice find that
middle ground now take some of it off
and that's what we did and then I it was
very important for me more than anything
to make sure that I got a sense of humor
his sense of um touch uh the way he
moved his body the way he felt free in
spaces or times when he didn't he felt
constrained so I wanted to really find
in every scene how he was different and
how he was taking information in his
body and that's what makes him human
that's what makes him vulnerable that
makes him real and that makes him like
you know you know it's like I I know
that the most beautiful thing is I know
that one of my dear friends says I don't
see you but I see you at the same time I
know it's not you but there's there's
the that that thing that you create with
your spirit for another person which is
beautiful it's a beautiful marriage so
that that's my hope that I didn't just
leave myself with the door but I brought
infused it with some of mine
too but he's his own such a beautiful
description right there and so
successful in all those respects this
might be overly prescribed and not
necessarily the way you tackled it but
given how many things you just listed
off is there a starting point like the
first thing you wrapped your head around
when playing byed but then also what was
the very last piece of the puzzle the
thing you were finally able to capture
that made you think like yep I got it
now I think one of the first
things that I tried to attempt to get is
his intelligence because he knew every
he knew so much he was a great organizer
and strategist and so I wanted to
download what he knew and how he would
go to India and get the teachings from
Gandhi uh to learn about passive
resistance I think that he was very much
a person of knowledge and travel
and so that that gave me a clue to who
he was you have images of his apartment
in Manhattan which is he's filled with
you know masks and and Canes he loves
walking sticks and chains and necklaces
and jewelry that gives you a sense of
who he was in the world you know what I
mean so you get all that stuff and you
download that and when I think I finally
found him is really when I found his
voice to be very honest where I found
that how he uses his voice cuz sometimes
in in rooms and in the film I will sort
of like you know make it a bit more
British in a way or make it a bit more
Mid-Atlantic standard and then sometimes
I actually take some a lot of it off of
it when he's just being very vulnerable
and in private spaces and he's not
performative in any way each time was um
once I sort of found that I understood
him more and IOD that it was a device
that creating your own language in a way
is a device why else would you do that
you know because first was question like
why would you do something like that
because you need to it's part of your
armor as well if you walk into one of
these rooms in the 1960s and you
suddenly have a British accent the world
must look at you differently right
right so true all right so you are
exceptional all on your own in this film
you also have a phenomenal Ensemble
around you and one thing I always love
highlighting in interviews is how many
different approaches to acting there are
out there so of everyone in this
Ensemble can you pinpoint two co-stars
with a completely different approach to
the work where when you're their scene
partner you know you all have a
different acting experience oh that's
great I would like to point out Amela
Meine who plays Martin Luther King and
Jeffrey and Jeffrey Wright Aela
Meine
is first of all I was always uh when we
started to play off of each
other I love that there was not any
Martin Luther King that I've experienced
before and I've experienced it because I
was actually in Selma with David Yo's
Martin Luther King which is profound but
this was all new this was grounded it
was actually a bit more vulnerable and
it was young and very human and I love
what he was bring so I had to look at
him and take out any that I have thought
I knew about M Luther King and
experienced what this is right here and
AEL and I we play an intimacy that I
think is rarely seen actually to be
honest be especially between a a queer
character and a straight character in
film especially with black men and it's
a delicacy and intimacy that we play
with each other which is beautiful uh of
true friendship and Brotherhood and then
you have Jeffrey Wright who is just
villainous
as all get out he was it was delicious
to him you could tell but he was really
he knew his function he came in he was
like oh no I'm the sort of the big bad
I'm the big bad in this uh in these
coalitions right now he he's a
northerner he comes you know just bues
the northern up he comes in and he's
like you know taking a piss on Martin
Luther King and everybody else because
you know it's Adam Clayton Pal's you
know bravado and his ego and Jeffrey
Wright what I love about him you you
never know what you're going to get from
take to take he's like me I think we
that's why we sort of vibe off of each
other because was like I don't know what
he's going to give me I don't know what
version of this is going what's going to
spark him in this moment it was
beautiful to watch and I loved and I
love the fact that most of the time I
just had to be you know just be shell
shocked at the information he was
pouring out at me which was be to
receive it was like he was just beating
me down which is beautiful what was it
like watching him go at it with Glenn
because one of my absolute favorite line
deliveries of the whole damn year is
when he says we have moved on I think I
have replayed that moment more than any
other seen in any film of 2023 let me
let me tell you there was one take where
Glenn Turman slammed his fist down on
the table and the Earth
shook because you have this first of all
this legendary actor the senior member
of our acting company with all the
gravitas in the world owning his
power he's you know truly owning his
power and when I tell you there was that
Lev all the actors were like whoa
Something's Happened happening now it's
it's phenomenal Glenn Turman is one of
my favorite actors to work with I work
with him over and over again he's just
pure class oh that moment that moment
just like rattled me to my core in the
best possible way all right I'm gonna
end here with another big question but
it's one that I find myself asking a lot
lately because I always like looking to
to the promising Futures out there and I
also like asking this question whenever
someone hits like a career Milestone
like having your first lead role in a
feature film
do you have any personal film making
goals that feel more Within Reach to you
than ever because you have played Rustin
and also just because this movie exists
I do I do I actually um there I I can't
say it just yet but there's I'm going to
make my directoral debut uh for a
feature film playing an American icon I
co-wrote the script and it's a movie
Musical
my mind right now I don't know if I'm
going to lose my mind or what because
I'm like now okay I'm going from my
first you know leading role in a feature
film to now slash slash slash slash
doing everything in the world so I might
have to get some pointers and tips from
uh Bradley Cooper and people like that
to say like am I crazy or but I actually
feel like I'm up for the task because I
I I know that I see it visually I I
understand it um dramaturgically and I
feel like it's like a painting I want to
do the whole painting and actually be in
it at the same time I'm so excited I
have all the faith in the world I look
forward to that I also look forward to
talking about this movie and your work
in it nonstop sincerely congratulations
on Rustin Perry thank you so
much